hey this is presh talwalkar
solve for the value of the following
three sums
the first sum is one divided by one
times three
plus one divided by three times five
plus one divided by five times seven
plus one divided by seven times nine
plus one divided by nine times eleven
the second sum is one divided by four
times seven plus one divided by seven
times ten plus one divided by ten times
thirteen plus one divided by thirteen
times sixteen
the third sum is an infinite series
one divided by two times seven plus one
divided by seven times 12 plus 1 divided
by 12 times 17 plus 1 divided by 17
times 22 and so on
i saw a mind bowling trick via study iq
mats on how to solve these types of
problems extremely quickly in your head
i want to share the solution to these
problems and i want to show a proof of
why this technique works
pause the video if you'd like to give
these problems a try and when you're
ready keep watching to learn how to
solve these problems
[Music]
i will first present solutions to these
problems and then i will give a proof of
why the technique works
let's get started with the first problem
so how do we solve this sum very quickly
first count the number of terms in the
sum
there are five terms
that's the numerator of the answer
we then divide by the following product
we take the very first number in the
first fraction that's 1 and we multiply
it by the very last number in the last
fraction
that's 11.
5 divided by one times eleven
one times eleven is equal to eleven
so the answer is five over eleven
and that's it
wow
let's use this technique to solve the
second problem
in this example we count the number of
terms in the sum
there are four terms in this sum
we then want to divide this by the very
first factor in the denominator that's 4
and we multiply this by the very last
factor in the last fraction
that's 16.
so we have 4 divided by 4 times 16.
we cancel out the 4s and we get this is
equal to 1 over 16
and that's the answer to this sum
now how do we solve for an infinite
series
we can't count the number of terms
because the number of terms is infinite
but there's a similar way to solve this
problem very quickly
the numerator is equal to one
we then divide by the very first factor
in the first fraction so that's two
then we look at the difference between
the two factors
so two to seven we want to add five here
so we take two in the denominator and
multiply it by five so one divided by
two times five that's equal to one over
ten and that's the answer to the
infinite series
i was so amazed by this trick
the question to me though is how does it
work
so now let's do a proof of why this
technique works
we start out with a general pattern for
all of these sums
so here is the finite sum of n terms
each term in the sum has the form
one divided by
k
multiplied by k plus d
so what we're going to do is we're going
to analyze each term in this sum
to do that we'll use a partial fraction
decomposition
this fraction will be equal to some
number p over k
plus some number q
divided by k plus d
we'll bring the k multiplied by k plus d
to the other side
then we will distribute
in the first term the k's will cancel
in the second term we have k plus d
cancelling out
we now will distribute the p term
and then we will group like terms
we will factor k
on the left hand side we have 1 and
that's equal to 1 plus k times 0.
we can now equate coefficients
we have 1 is equal to p multiplied by d
this means p is equal to one over d
then we have p plus q is equal to zero
we just solved that p is equal to one
over d
so that means q is equal to negative one
over d
we now can solve for the partial
fraction decomposition
p is equal to 1 over d and q is equal to
negative 1 over d
we'll just move this negative sign to
the second term over here so we have the
partial fraction decomposition that this
is equal to one over d divided by k
minus one over d divided by k plus d
we will use this formula on each term in
this sum so let's apply it on the first
term
here k is equal to a
so the partial sum we apply this formula
then we will apply it to the second term
now in this k is equal to a plus d
so we apply the formula and we'll keep
doing this for every single term in this
sum
we get an interesting pattern here
in particular
the second and third terms will cancel
out
then
the fourth and fifth terms will cancel
out and this pattern will continue
to the penultimate term
so only the very first term and the very
last term will survive
so the partial sum will be equal to the
following
and i want to mention this is an example
of something interesting when you have a
sum or only the very beginning and the
very end survive that's reminiscent of a
telescope that retracts upon itself
for this reason this is known as a
telescoping sum
so we figured out the partial sum is
equal to 1 over d divided by a minus 1
over d divided by a plus nd
we now need to simplify this
we'll move the d terms to the
denominator
then we will get a common denominator
we can simplify the numerator this will
be equal to nd
then we have a d factor in the numerator
and the denominator so the d's will
cancel out
so the partial sum is equal to n divided
by a multiplied by the factor a plus nd
and this is exactly the formula we want
n is the numerator that's the number of
terms in the sum
then a is exactly that very first factor
and then a plus nd is the very last
factor you know the largest number in
the sum
so that's it that's why this formula
works
now what about the infinite series
in that case we want to take the limit
as n approaches infinity of the partial
sum
so let's rewrite the partial sum by
distributing in the denominator
then we take a look as n goes to
infinity so we'll focus on just the n
terms
now n over n
will cancel out in a way so we have 1
over a d
so the limit as n goes to infinity of
the partial sum will be equal to 1
divided by a multiplied by d
now a is exactly this first factor in
the first denominator and then d is the
difference between these two terms
a plus d minus a is equal to d
and that's a proof of the infinite
series formula
this is a wonderful formula that not
everyone knows so if you see it on an
exam or competition you'll have the edge
to solve it very quickly in your head
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time